did you know there's a new way to create
vertex AI conversation agents using llms
instead of defining flows Pages intents
and transitions you provide natural
language instructions and structure data
in the form of playbooks A playbook is
the basic building block of an agent and
an agent typically has many playbooks
each defined to handle specific tasks
The Playbook data is provided to the llm
so it has the information it needs to
answer questions and execute tasks each
Playbook can provide information send
queries to external services or defer
conversation handling to a traditional
flow or another Playbook to handle
subtasks all significantly reducing the
agent creation and maintenance time and
enabling brand new types of
conversational experiences